Salut aujourd'hui on va parler de l'énigme
et je voulais tourner cette explication en extérieur
je suis à Rouen en ce moment,
et il fait pas très beau
c'est même un temps complètement déprimant.
mais on n'est pas là pour parler de la météo !
Alors c'est parti : énigme et solution !!
Au final je tourne dans ma chambre d'hôtel à Rouen
je sais pas trop ce que ça va donner au niveau de la lumière ...
je vous rappelle qu'il ne reste plus que 5 villes pour voir le spectacle
et après ce sera trop tard pour un mental roadage
il reste : Nice, la Suisse à Champéry,
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine, Moret sur Loing et Nantes
pour deux représentations mais la deuxième est quasiment complète.
Pour gagner mon trophée des 100 000 abonnés, il y a quelques temps j'ai créé
une énigme pour ça. Et cette énigme
il y avait des indices qui traînaient déjà dans d'autres vidéos.
On va tout reprendre point par point.
L'énigme en elle-même je vous la remets ici.
Comme ça si vous voulez la faire, il est encore temps
pour le plaisir de la faire en fait.
Et je vais détailler les points un par un
comme ça si vous bloquez quelque part
vous pouvez arrêter de regarder la vidéo une fois que vous êtes débloqué
et essayer de la terminer seul.
Je vous détaille la vidéo énigme de 30 secondes.
Au tout départ, il y a marqué: "Trouvez les bons chiffres."
"Indices dans la vidéo du 8 avril"
Dans la vidéo du 8 avril, si on regardait bien,
y avait des petits flashs subliminaux.
A 0 minute 0 seconde de cette vidéo
on pouvait voir apparaître "fibonnaci début"
et à 8 minutes, "fibonnaci fin".
Ca c'était juste un guide pour vous permettre de trouver
où est-ce qu'étaient placés les flashs subliminaux et combien y en avait.
Entre 0 et 8, il n'y a que 1, 2, 3, 5 de la suite de Fibonacci.
Donc ça voulait dire qu'il fallait choper le mot à l'intervalle 1'00, 2'00, 3'00 et 5'00
et surtout qu'il n'y en avait que 4.
Ca permettait d'être sûr et certain d'avoir tous les mots.
Y avait également dans la description de cette vidéo un lien
vers une page de mon site Internet
où je parlais de l'effet de Stroop où vous pouviez télécharger d'ailleurs ces fichiers
pour les mettre sur votre téléphone et les tester sur vos amis.
Ceux qui ont eu la curiosité d'aller voir et de descendre en-bas
de l'article sur Stroop, ont pu lire la phrase suivante:
Si un jour vous tombez sur une énigme pensez à chercher la clé de décryptage cachée.
La description d'une clé cachée? La réponse est dans la question.
Cela veut dire que dans la description de la vidéo se cache la clé...
Et dans la description en elle-même de la vidéo, toujours,
y avait un indice brut, avec marqué: "Vigenère".
Pour ceux qui connaissent pas Vigenère, si on tape "Vigenère" sur Google
on tombe directement sur les explications de ce qu'est un code de Vigenère.
C'est un cryptage, assez complexe, pour des messages secrets
qui fonctionne avec une clé.
Heureusement aujourd'hui, y a plein de sites qui permettent de décrypter le code de Vigenère.
Si vous avez les mots et la clé, ça peut crypter et décrypter dans les deux sens;
y a plein de sites gratuits pour ça.
Il ne manquait donc plus que la clé.
Il fallait trouver la clé.
Et alors la clé du code de Vigenère, elle était extrêmement simple,
il suffisait de regarder la description de la vidéo en question,
et de prendre la première lettre de chaque phrase.
Et si on prend la première lettre de chaque phrase, ça fait "MENTAL VLOGS"...
Avec un S! Ca c'était le petit piège!
Donc vous aviez "MENTAL VLOGS" avec un S, ça pouvait sauter aux yeux
parce que toutes les lettres étaient en majuscules.
Donc en décodant avec la méthode de Vigenère
et la clé "MENTAL VLOGS" avec un S
les quatre mots que vous aviez pris aux intervalles de Fibonacci,
on trouvait: "GAUCHE GAUCHE DROITE GAUCHE".
Dans la vidéo, au moment où s'affiche donc: "Trouvez les bons chiffres",
en fond, y a toute une séquence avec: "DDGD" ... et des chiffres en-dessous...
"GGDG", des chiffres en-dessous, etc. etc.
Eh bien "GAUCHE GAUCHE DROITE GAUCHE" ça fait un peu des codes de rétro-gaming
Ca fait "GAUCHE GAUCHE DROITE GAUCHE": G-G-D-G.
C'est exactement l'indice que vous aviez trouvé.
En-dessous de "GGDG", était marqué: "17-12".
Et justement, que nous dit la suite de la vidéo énigme?
Elle nous dit: "Comparez l'énigme"
Donc c'est ça, vous compariez le "GAUCHE GAUCHE DROITE GAUCHE" avec tout ce qu'y avait à l'écran
et vous obteniez "17-12"... ou "1712"...
Je viens déjà de cramer la suite de la réponse d'ailleurs!
Et la question suivante dans l'énigme était:
"Quelle photo de mon Instagram correspond à ces chiffres-là?"
Et si on va sur mon Insta, on peut chercher une photo où y a marqué "17-12",
enfin "1712" en gros.
Mais y avait quand même un piège, c'est-à-dire que
tous les chiffres qui étaient sur le fond avec les mauvais codes,
les mauvais indices, correspondaient aussi à une photo.
Ca c'est mon petit côté pervers!!!
Donc la photo concernée avec "17-12", c'était celle-ci.
Là où y a marqué "COMPLET".
Et la suite de la vidéo énigme était: "Quelle est la ville associée?"
Donc si on regarde, la ville associée, c'était Paris.
La suite de l'énigme vous renvoie encore sur une nouvelle vidéo
où il faut chercher une suite de 5 chiffres.
Une séquence de 5 chiffres.
Avec la petite précision que c'est à l'intérieur de Pi.
A la toute fin de cette nouvelle vidéo indice,
on pouvait avoir quelque chose à l'envers, assez rapide, mais
je trouve que ça sautait aux yeux,
et si on le retournait, on pouvait lire l'indice suivant:
"La troisième ligne".
Et dans la description, y a encore un indice...
Y avait toujours un indice dans la description...
Là, c'était: "La statue a un épi".
Ce qu'il fallait comprendre, c'est qu'au moment précis
où la statue de la liberté apparaissait dans la vidéo,
il fallait regarder la troisième ligne de Pi.
Mais pas Pi, n'importe où, n'importe comment...
C'était un T-shirt de Pi que j'avais, avec une chemise.
Et à ce moment précis de la vidéo, j'avais fait en sorte que ma chemise
s'arrête précisément pour avoir une entrée et une sortie de chiffres sur la troisième ligne du T-shirt.
On pouvait donc lire: "9-7-1-6-9".
Et ça c'est la séquence qu'il fallait trouver avec le jeu de mots "La statue a un éPI".
En fait c'était pour la statue de la liberté et Pi...
Au moment où elle apparaissait à la vidéo, il fallait regarder la troisième ligne de mon T-shirt.
La vidéo énigme, elle nous dit ensuite:
"La ville + la suite de chiffres... sans majuscule et sans espace...
= le mot de passe". Le mot de passe est donc:
"PARIS97169".
A ce moment précis, vous aviez quasiment fini de résoudre l'énigme.
Puisque dans la description de la vidéo énigme, je vous envoyais sur une page de mon site Internet
où j'avais créé la fin de l'énigme.
Y avait 10 pages possibles où vous pouviez cliquer
pour terminer ça. Mais ces 10 pages étaient protégées par un code secret.
Et le code secret, c'était donc "PARIS97169".
Là où ça se corsait, c'est que les 10 pages s'ouvraient avec le même mot de passe
donc vous n'aviez pas l'assurance d'être sur la bonne page en ayant le mot de passe.
Pour ça, y avait un indice à trouver.
La vidéo énigme disait la chose suivante:
"Dans la dernière vidéo indice, une phrase vous indiquera plus tard le bon choix".
Dans la vidéo indice, je vous expliquais que dans la vidéo en elle-même se cachait une phrase entière,
une phrase qu'il fallait que vous trouviez.
Et je disais d'un petit air malicieux: "Pour la trouver, il faudra en montrer plus".
Donc en montrer plus, ça voulait dire: fallait lire la description.
Ensuite je disais: "Le premier mot de cette phrase commence à l'alternance".
Et je terminais par dire: "A très bientôt dans le futur, ciao".
"A très bientôt dans le futur" faisait référence à "Retour vers le futur" évidemment
dont j'avais 3 figurines au-dessus.
Et l'alternance avec ce geste,
c'est parce que à un moment donné dans la vidéo, Doc et Marty s'inversent sur mon étagère.
C'est ça le début de l'alternance.
Y avait marqué qu'il fallait entendre quelque chose et voir quelque chose.
Ce qu'on entendait, c'est: "On n'est pas".
C'est-à-dire qu'à 4'21 et 7 centièmes, on entend: "On n'est pas",
et la deuxième chose elle se voyait, c'était le mot: "silencieux".
Donc "On n'est pas silencieux".
et "On n'est pas silencieux" c'est la phrase clé pour savoir où cliquer parmi les 10 pages possibles sur le site.
Ca va ? Je vous perds pas trop ?!
Donc en cliquant sur la page "On n'est pas silencieux", en tapant ensuite le mot de passe "PARIS97169"
et on avait le formulaire où il y avait juste à répondre.
Le record est de 18 minutes après la sortie de la vidéo.
Quelqu'un a trouvé la réponse à l'énigme 18 minutes après la sortie de la vidéo.
Et la personne donc qui a eu le record, qui a été la plus rapide, elle s'appelle Laure-Anne et elle habite à Paris.
Laure-Anne, tu habites même dans le 20ème.Voilà, je ne donne pas plus sur toi, mais c'est pour que tu puisses te reconnaître.
Vous avez été exactement 331 à trouver la bonne réponse.
Donc bravo ! Et vous avez été plus de 4000 à participer en tout.
Et là double bravo !
C'est-à-dire que... ce n'est pas très grave de ne pas avoir trouvé, l'important c'est de s'être challengé et de s'être stimulé pour essayer de résoudre quelque chose d'assez complexe en fait.
C'était pas très compliqué dans le sens où il n'y avait pas des calculs incroyables à faire mais il fallait vraiment de la réflexion, tester des pistes...
chercher des pistes qui n'étaient pas très visibles, pas très évidentes.
Il y avait aussi beaucoup de fausses pistes.
Donc bravo de l'avoir fait.
Maintenant sur les 331 personnes, je vais en tirer une au hasard.
[rempli en ligne le tirage au sort] Valeur minimum: 1..., Valeur maximum: 100...
Le nombre d'éléments à séléctionner par tirage: 1 seul
Générer....
Et le résultat c'est 42.
La ligne 43, puisque la première ligne elle comporte ça.
La ligne 43 qui est donc ici... [cherche le numéro]
Et c'est...
Et c'est Lauric qui habite dans le 94.
Alors je ne sais pas trop comment je vais monter le tirage au sort, parce qu'il ne faut pas que je dévoile des infos personnelles.
Lauric du 94, bravo.
Comme tu es dans le 94, c'est pas extrêmement loin de Paris, je vais t'envoyer un mail et si tu veux on se rencontre pour que je t'offre le trophée et on fera une petit vidéo qu'on mettra sur mon compte Instagram.
Et si vous qui regardez la vidéo vous ne suivez pas mon compte Instagram, prenez le temps de me rajouter ça me ferait vraiment plaisir.
C'est FabienOlicard tout attaché.
Ce n'est pas un compte certifié parce que je n'ai pas de certification Insta.
C'est un petit compte pour l'instant qui a 7000 abonnés.
Mais vous pouvez me rajouter ça me ferait plaisir.
Alors y avait aussi deux autres vidéos indices, dont je n'ai pas parlé dans la vidéo énigme.
La dernière qui annonçait le jour de sortie de la vidéo énigme, ainsi que son heure de sortie pour être au taquet avant tout le monde,
et une autre au milieu de tout ça qui comportait un code, je ne sais pas si vous l'avez trouvé,
je ne sais pas si vous avez trouvé à quoi ça sert,
mais ça... je vais le laisser en suspens...
Je le rappelle, il y a mon livre qui sort le 18 mai, qui est déjà en pré commande sur Amazone, à la Fnac, chez votre libraire préféré.
On trouve également quelques extraits à droite à gauche, je vais vous mettre un lien dans la description.
Je ne sais pas encore si je ferai une vidéo dessus.
Ca dépendra un petit peu de vous, peut être une en non répertoriée, enfin on verra ça...
Et j'ai un dernier truc à vous dire, vraiment. J'espère que vous êtes encore là en fait j'aurai dû le dire dès le départ:
Les deux dernières vidéos que j'ai faites, elles sont allées dans les tendances Youtube, donc ça ça fait toujours plaisir.
Mais surtout je voulais vous dire un truc: ce sont des vidéos avec des vignettes très classiques, des titres très classiques,
donc j'ai cherché à analyser pourquoi elles étaient allées dans les tendances.
Et... parce qu'elles ne sont pas pour le coup sexy ou putaclic comme vous dites à tout bout de champ. [rires]
Et bien en fait, c'est simplement avec la masse de pouces que vous avez mis.
L'avant dernière vidéo, il y en avait plus de 40 000. Là je crois qu'il y en a plus de 15 000 sur la dernière.
Heu...
Merci en fait parce que c'est aussi une manière de valoriser ces fameux titres et vignettes qui ne sont pas putaclic.
Vous récompensez ça et ça les met dans les tendances et c'est aussi comme ça que vous maîtrisez vous aussi le game.
Bravo à vous et merci à vous !
A très bientôt ! Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]